in good shape your weekly dose of health
information on deutsche welle find out
more about what's new in medical
treatment alternative medicine as well
as nutrition wellness and beauty medical
professionals therapists and counselors
are in our studio to offer their expert
advice on in good shape with me in the
studio today is an expert on the medical
use of cannabis let me welcome professor
Marcos lyrica he's a psychiatrist at the
Manheim central institute of mental
health and he's been doing research on
cannabis for nearly 20 years now welcome
to in good shape ragazza hello what
effect does cannabis has on the body in
for pain medication for pain it's an
interesting effect it's basically that
we have two fats basically two classes
of fats the one that actually induces
peripheral pain and we just learned that
this the other class that includes a
endogenous cannabinoids that basically
counterbalance effect of the bad fats so
you could use cannabis as a drug there
for her to to get a better pain and I'm
could you even just smoked a joint
looking at joint this is a bit critical
in my view there's one aspect that you
have to keep in mind the cannabis plant
contains more than 70 different
cannabinoids so it's not only THC's a
constituent that makes you high there
other compounds and the distribution of
these compounds within the plant it's
basically dependent from type of plant
growing conditions and so on so if you
smoke pot for medical purposes you
probably don't see the same effect each
time because the ingredients are
different okay and it's not only used
for pain actually so what affliction
says kind of us help especially well the
bodies and doggedness cannabinoid system
is basically whiteley this
buted a lot of systems and the bodies
that used this system or this and
endocannabinoid system to get back into
homeostasis which means it brings you
back to resting state so having that set
it's basically that you see a lot of
disorders where the endocannabinoid
system plays all and because you target
the endocannabinoid system by exogenous
kind of in its plant alive cannabinoids
or synthetic ones you basically can
address a whole lot of diseases like
epilepsy even tumors and doctors do give
the cannabis as pills or as a shot so
how do you administer it in in Germany's
its prescribe herbal as a kind of
capsule it's either meinl which is Delta
9 THC as a one compound in pure form or
you can or even the pharmacist may
prepare these capsules for you and
there's a second other two other ways to
prescribe it so one is no big smalls
which is a mixture of cannabidiol as a
counter player of THC and the plant and
THC so it's one to one and there's also
a synthetic cannabinoid delivered that
you can use for to prevent vomiting
after chemotherapy which is not alone
what about the risk of addiction with
those tablets this is an addictive
compound so Delta 9 THC okay so let's go
for diction but I think in a medical
context you have to keep in mind there's
also a large risk of addiction for
opioids and they're widely used in a
medical context and to be controlled by
and exactly describe it so resolute
occurred you where the first position in
the world who use cannabis for the
treatment of schizophrenic patients and
how many patients benefit it first I
would like to say
we didn't use cannabis we just used
purified can we dial one of the main
ingredients and as I said this is a
counter player of Delta 9 THC so
compounds that actually induces
psychotic symptoms so this is important
to make the difference it's not cannabis
because cannabis armful in schizophrenia
the majority of studies point to this
direction it increases the risk to
suffer schizophrenia and we actually try
to avoid these effects and just used one
single compound to induce a certain
effect that we expected so you would not
in any circumstances recommend some
patients with schizophrenia to smoke
some pot to get cured no I wouldn't okay
so and why are those natural substances
you used better than those established
medication you can usually get from your
doctor I don't know if Sarah Lee better
because the number of patients that
we've treated is too small to really say
it's superior or it's equal a lot more
studies are needed and we are just
performing a large-scale European
clinical trial using cannabidiol in
early schizophrenia which is put in the
first three years and in acute stages
and this is funded by the European
Commission so we definitely need to have
more information available on this point
but on the other hand this is just a new
mechanism of action so conventional
compounds use certain mechanisms of
action and certain patients don't
respond to this and we use a different
mechanism and this the basic thing that
makes it special there's a study that
shows that cannabis may even help in
patients with Alzheimer's diseases very
promising what do you think about that I
think because the system is so important
to to remain homeostasis in the body
it's highly likely that it's also
activated during Alzheimer's
this may be a promising target that we
haven't addressed yet and we have to see
if this is really something that holds
up in larger studies so this is all very
interesting very very new what's in the
pipeline for cannabis in the next decade
say there are several approaches
basically the one is a plant-derived
material to look into specific compounds
of the plant but there are also
synthetic cannabinoid modulators that in
use certain effects some of them even
don't cause a blood brain barrier so the
effect is limited to the periphery and
this is in under certain circumstances
very useful if you want to avoid a
central nervous I'd effects yeah a lot
of research to be done thank you for
silicon for being with us in the studio
thank you so much
you